everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse and yesterday we talked about a
lot of things for this new project today
we're actually going to start the
project so what I'd like to accomplish
today is to get Gatsby up and running
and of course that's it's going to be
react right we're just going to use
Gatsby to help build up build us out
react and add some some features so that
we don't have to worry about that and
I'd like to make a github repo and then
that way you all can have the link you
can see the code follow along and
contribute as we go through everything
so I before we start I just want to say
if anyone has any reason why you think
we should not use Gatsby with this
project let me know now I mean we could
switch later on but it's going to be
easier to decide that now so I have not
used Gatsby before I've checked out the
documentation I think it will work but
maybe I'm missing something so with that
being said let's get started also I do
want to apologize for anybody who tried
to watch my second stream yesterday the
the guest lecture that I gave at the
computer science course the network was
just terrible so the audio only came
through not really the video so okay
someone in the live chat asked if I'm
sleepy I'm really sleepy so I can see
what I look like on video I think we can
barely keep my eyes open so I was I was
here for a long time yesterday I got
home late and then woke up in the middle
of the night and couldn't go back to
sleep and then woke up early with my
three-year-old and watch my little pony
at 5:00 a.m. so anyway but I just had
some coffee I'm gonna do my best to to
stay awake all right so I'm going to use
this Pomodoro timer if you're not
familiar with how we do things here on
the stream we have Pomodoro sessions
where you do 25 minutes of code and then
we take a five-minute break and I go to
the live chat see what you all are
saying answer some questions then we go
back to 25 minutes of coding and we just
go back and forth like that today I
think I'd like to get at least two
Pomodoro sessions in and then we'll just
see how things are going after that
maybe we'll do another one maybe not so
if I don't get your question right away
just hang on for a little while and I'll
get to it during one of the breaks so
let me start the timer by the way this
timer was built by someone in our live
chat who watches these dreams and
contributes so thanks Harshit for
building this really cool let's get
started all right okay so if you want to
follow along with the Gatsby
documentation it's Gatsby j/s dot org so
really easy URL and then just click on
the docs and we're just we're gonna
start just with basic basic install here
so we're gonna learn add and then I
believe the flag is just g4 yarn to do
global and we're gonna install this whoa
missa missa packages
did I mess it up maybe I added
maybe it's not cheap
all right let's check it out I haven't
installed anything globally with yarn in
quite some time so let me double check
where we are dogs
okay darn global and okay I just put it
in the wrong spot whoa
gone global ad where we at Gatsby CLI
okay we got to do this first to be able
to build our project with gatsby so
we're installing it globally because
that way we can build out the projects
from anyway I mean it makes sense when
you have things like create react tap
next
or Gatsby things like that global
install makes sense rare I rarely use a
global install but occasionally it is
worth it alright so I'm gonna see the
into my projects folder and let's do
mm-hmm
Gatsby I guess we have to pick a starter
so let me double check oh no I'm sorry I
never switched my screen haha thanks for
letting me know sorry
yeah I'm not used to having the full
screen thing I just I just started
trying it yesterday so I'll have to
remember that okay so let me just go
back you didn't miss much you just must
be typing the wrong thing in a couple of
times um so all we did was yarn global
add Gatsby CLI and it installed it and
then I went into my projects folder
that's it so not really not not really
anything big yet okay now we're gonna go
to Gatsby oops
Kessie starter i guess we're gonna use
gatsby starter hello world so Gatsby has
quite a few like starter projects so
normally like with create react app it's
just basic you know you get the same
thing no matter what but with Gatsby
there are different versions of the
basic install so I'm just gonna go with
the hello world one because it seems to
me like that'll probably be the most
basic for us to build off of I did find
one that was supposed to be material
design base but I wasn't thrilled with
all of the styles so I don't think I'm
gonna go with that one
all right so let's go with SB
what we're gonna call this Franciscan
site I guess I guess that works
do we have to use a starter can you just
actually let me say this if we don't
have to use a starter that'll be cool
let's just see what happens
all right cool then I don't have to
decide what starter to use that works
for me
all right so this should not take very
long and when it's ready we should have
a dev server already
taking a little longer than I thought
there we go all right still not bad
under a minute
all right let's CD into that folder
there we go and now we're gonna do I'm
gonna have to get used to all their
commands what is a Gatsby develop okay
okay okay so we've got this running
localhost 8,000
and see what we have here we go
so we have our Gatsby site here it's
already set up with with two pages so
that's cool all right and we're also
going to want to use the command line as
well so I'm going to duplicate this tab
so now we can do commands in here and we
can have our our local server running
all right so I'm trying to check keep up
at least a little with the with a live
chat all right so let's go into the the
project structure here and see what's
going on I like I said I've never done
Gatsby before so I'm a little bit
interested in and how they do things so
I'm gonna use Adam at least to start
this project out as my as my editor all
right so let's check out our
package.json first I'm gonna make this
bigger so you all can see it and let's
move it over to this side so it doesn't
get blocked by by the video in the
corner
cool so starter oh cool so it looks like
it came with helmet already that's gonna
help when we put in like title tags and
things for our pages and let's see what
we have build develop okay it already
has formatting interesting that's cool
so right off the bat it's giving us some
formatting with prettier I like that
that's nice
very nice all right cool see see what
sooner we already have a readme it's
just a fault we'll change that but
that's not anything to worry about now
we have a gas B config okay cool so we
have metadata not bad here's what our
pages are so right now our routing is
taken care of by any component that we
put in this pages folder becomes a page
it's it's actually a route so this was
our home page and this was our page to
where we clicked on and you see they're
just stateless functional components
let's where'd it go
let's get my screens in order here there
we are
okay so right so this is that that index
that page one and then we go to page two
you could it's going to be hard to see
but in our URL actually changes and page
two is at the end so really simple
routing we're probably going to want to
do some programmatic routing and not
just probably we are going to want to do
programmatic routing later on but for
now this is this is great it also comes
with a 404 page and we can customize
that which is really awesome we'll
definitely want to do that as well and
let's check our layouts great so we
already have a layout page mate I really
like that that's cool this is where
we're probably going to want to put yeah
we'll probably end up putting our header
at least our header in there maybe our
footer as well
yeah and we're gonna want to yeah we're
gonna want this meta data to change
based on the page but you know we we can
get to that a little bit later on but
otherwise I like this this is a nice
this is a nice setup to start so so far
so good with Gatsby we don't need to
worry about these at this point I do
want to make sure we have a good ignore
that's sufficient for this project we
don't have a dot end yet but we will
probably have it eventually so I'm just
going to throw it in there right now
okay cool
see okay so here's our next step let's
start I guess we can make this a git
repo now I'll let you guys help me out
with this decision do we want to make it
a git repo right now knowing that we
have to make a lot of like really basic
changes do we want to have all those
commits in there or should we build it
out a little bit first and then commit
so anyway let me know I'll check the
look back at the live shot in in just a
second
but in the meantime we need to figure
out how we're going to style this all
right I do know I wanted to go from
scratch and try to style this in our
previous project we used material UI the
new the beta version of material UI I in
terms of what it looks like and what it
can do I really like it I know that that
some of you had some issues with there's
a little bit complicated to get some
things to work but I really I don't know
of an alternative to material UI that's
as completes and has all the components
that we need so I think I'm just gonna
go with material UI again okay so it
looks like Tiffany and no Beerse and
hacker you see so everybody's kind of
saying do a little bit first and then
commit okay cool that's what I usually
do
oh okay Philips saying get from the
start I don't know I usually build out a
little bit because I just think like
what am I gonna write in my get commit
like I deleted all the boilerplate demo
code like these in commit anyway all
right you know what let's just do it
let's just make it a git repo from the
and that way if anything anybody has
anything to say about what UI framework
we're going to use it'll give you a
couple more minutes to to say it so if
you're not familiar with get I'm gonna
explain what's going on here and then
I'm gonna switch it over to github and
we're gonna put our git repo and get up
and I'll explain everything so don't
worry if you're totally new to get and
github or even using the terminal I'll
do my best to explain things and for
those of you who who already know all
this stuff it's it's gonna be a little
bit boring for you so I apologize but I
don't want to leave anybody behind if I
don't have to okay so from the
command-line I already have git
installed so if you've never installed
get on your machine you have to do that
first but assuming you've done that
which is not a difficult process
assuming you've done that you can just
go get in it make sure you're inside
your project folder which we are here
and then you hit enter and it says I've
initialized an empty you get repository
okay now I just have this well it'll
depend on your terminal now you have it
set up but when I end it a repository I
have a hashtag there we could do a git
status to see what's going on and any
time you're not sure what's going on
with your git repo type git status and
it'll let you know if there are files
that need to be committed so right now
here are all the files that we're not
doing anything with yet we haven't added
them we had it Kim having committed them
but we definitely want these files there
you don't want all your files to be
committed that's what I get ignores for
so I showed this earlier our get ignored
tells get which files to ignore right it
makes sense so specifically the one we
always want to ignore is our node
modules there's a lot of stuff in node
modules so I mean that's insane look at
all that stuff it's out
accord I'm only on D scrolling down
there so we don't want to put that on
github right we don't need it our
package JSON tells somebody's note or
MPN our yarn which modules to install so
they can clone the repository download
it and they can run NPM or yarn on their
machines and get all those packages so
it definitely cuts down on the amount of
files and folders that get set up to to
get up okay so what we want to do
oops is do gits let me put this up I
don't want it to get blocked there we go
so we're gonna do gets add and I'm just
gonna put a dot that means we're adding
everything alright and let's you says is
that okay so when we do a git status
again and now these are all green that
means they've been added they're ready
to to commit I guess they call it stage
right it's not added it's um they're
staged anyway we want to do a git commit
and we can also add a flag that's em and
that means we're just gonna put a
message for our commit just to let
people know what we're changing and
we're going to add that message in line
if you don't add that then whatever you
have set up as your default editor is
going to open up and you're gonna have
to make a message in there so this say
it's just a little bit of time it's nice
if you you know don't really have a long
commit message so get commit em and
we're just going to say I'm gonna say an
it usually my first commit no matter
what I always just call an it for
basically for initial commit or
initialize or you know ever you want to
think about that and I'm gonna hit enter
and there we go
everything's added we can check do to
get status again and now it says we're
on the master branch and there's nothing
to commit and if we look back
here depending on how you have what
editor you're using you should have some
things happen that when you go and it's
not working for me right now at figures
but what should happen is you should
have some type of visual indicator when
you've changed a file so let's see this
is gonna break things but oh well it's
not working for me
I was disabling some packages and adding
some new packages to add them so maybe I
messed something up anyway now we want
to add this to github so let me have
pull this down a bit and we'll go back
to our browser and let's go to github so
this is my github let me make everything
bigger so we can see normally github
does not look like this this is the
github dark theme so search github for
the github dark theme and you'll you can
you can do this too so what we're gonna
do first is go create we're going to new
repository so we click new repository
and in this case I want to switch it up
so it's this FUS mark on so that's I
work at Franciscan University of stew
mill and I'm in the marketing
communications department so we have our
own github organization so I'm gonna
make that the owner and then we're gonna
call this Franciscan
Franciscan reacts I guess that works
that's fine I'm kind of terrible at
naming things at first it's hard to come
up with something we'll give it a short
description
okay that's good enough for now we're
gonna make this a public repository so
you all can see it and we already ever
read me so we're not gonna initialize
with a readme and I believe we already
have a license we do so we don't need a
license so we're not going to add this
we already have a get ignore so you
don't need to add any of this and we're
gonna create the repo okay now we come
to this screen so we want to go down
here to push an existing repository
right because we've already made the
repository on our local machine so let's
grab this code and this this is already
filled in with the correct code for you
for that repo so this already says
Franciscan - react so we're gonna copy
that and paste it here and then let's
copy that next line so basically what
this just did is is added so git remote
add origin so we've added this as our
remote okay now we're gonna push and
that's what we're going to use to get
our code up onto github we're going to
use push but this is our our first push
and I got to enter my key usually I
don't have to enter unless I restart my
computer which I did recently so on my
other screen I'm going into my last pass
so I can get my oh so I get my key
okay so let's put that key in there now
everything has gone up to github so you
all should be able to see that now I'm
gonna paste a link into the live chat
and then I'm also gonna have a link in
the description to this video and all
the future videos on this project so now
I want to do SSH ad because I don't
wanna have to type that key in again so
that'll save its status I was like oh I
guess I I did modify the get ignored
didn't I
there we go and in case you wonder what
was going on there
I had added a few lines just just hit
enter a few times so alright my first
session first 25-minute session is up so
not bad we got Gatsby going and got a
development environment set up and we
also got a git repo setup so now I'm
gonna do a short break
and I'm going to go to a live shot and
go up to the top and then scroll down
through and try to get as many questions
answer it as I can
okay
okay so I got a question about the
Pomodoro clock so Jessie McIntyre says
why Pomodoro I'm used to I've been used
to using Pomodoro for a while now on my
own and this is it's kind of a nice way
to break up the work so I I like using
Pomodoro in the stream in particular I
like using it because it reminds me to
stop and check out the live chat and
then it also reminds me to stop looking
at the live chat and then get back to
work so it's it's kind of a nice break
and if you don't know that much about
Pomodoro it's really cool I check into
it I may do a video on Pomodoro
at some point but let's see
anyway it's basically a nice way to
break up your time
so when I forgot to switch my screen I
had some some funny comments here so it
just talked in your going to show you
your screen I mean you're not bad to
look at but I came to see some code I
leave that comment yeah sorry about that
I will do my best to not make that same
mistake again okay Philip has a question
about lodash sort by saying is there a
way to prioritize a sort condition if
the object met two conditions I'm not
familiar with lodash short by so I'm not
really able to answer that if anybody
watching is good with with lodash
particularly sort by you know feel free
to to put an answer there in the live
chat for Philip deepak says thanks you
for sharing your time with us you're
welcome
all right so Lucas asked what is Gatsby
if you're familiar with create react app
or next j/s or any other things like
that Gatsby is in that same category
it lets you honestly I guess like
scaffold a react project and usually
these types of things come built in with
a lot of extras that wouldn't be with
just you know your basic react setup so
will will be kind of working through and
using some of those extras but you can
see already from the from our
package.json just a few of the extras
right we have prettier this is gonna be
like formatting of our code so we have
some Auto formatting of code in there we
have helmet which is going to help us to
add proper title tags and metadata to
our pages so just right off the bat
there's a few things there's a lot of
other stuff which we'll get to you know
in future streams
hi super says Gatsby is kind of like
Jekyll which is a static site generator
it's it's modern WordPress with add-on
single page application features yeah
actually I forgot about Jekyll yeah so
yeah Gatsby does call itself a static
site generator so that would be the the
class of what it is John Hanson says is
it easy to migrate code from a create
react app project to a Gatsby project I
would think yes because components are
components still and reacts right so it
shouldn't be an issue
if we want to pull some components from
from projects that we've done earlier
like particularly the last project and
reuse them so like the header the side
drawer we should definitely pull in some
of those components assuming that we're
going to use the same UI framework I
think it would make sense to pull in
those components instead of completely
recreating them we're definitely gonna
have to modify them but it'll save us a
lot of time if we can reuse as much code
as possible okay so all of my or my time
is up in this break so we're going to do
another 25 minutes of coding and I
didn't get through everything in the
live chat but I will get through let's
see I'll get through everything on our
next break
okay so at this point let me get it let
me put a link for the repo and so here's
our repository so you see really basic
right now I'm gonna paste that link into
the live chat and now you all can check
it out
right now not much to it but we will be
adding code to this pretty much every
day for a while and now let's go
I guess we'll add material UI
I'm just gonna double-check and see in
the part of the live chat that I didn't
look at yet if anything was said about
UI frameworks
hmm okay I'm not seeing it I'm scrolling
through pretty quickly so I may be
missing it I just realized that I have
the font size really small on the chat
window which is silly
I keep squinting so I just brought that
up brought that font size up a bit okay
yeah let's let's grab the latest version
of material UI and in fact let's go over
to our previous projects that we're
actually not finished with yet but we're
still working on and let's check our
package JSON and just see if there's
anything else we'd like to bring over so
this is project 4 we did a lot of videos
about this project so if you're
interested in this this was done with
create react app instead of Gatsby but I
think well we had like 15 16 streams on
this so we it has its own playlist and I
believe it's clearly labeled react
project 4 okay
where's our dependencies I think a lot
of this we will not need most of these
were for what we were doing on our
custom server okay
should be good I guess
we do want to grab material you I I want
to make sure we're grabbing the latest
version so I'm not just going to get
this I want to see what the latest
version is I think I may want to put in
some of this thing some of the stuff
with testing and Auto formatting but I'm
going to hold off on that for now so
first things first let's check out
material UI and we're going to use the
version 1 beta let's see what it says
next alright so we can use material on
next
okay and then we're also going to want
to grab those icons as well fits your UI
okay oops so we're gonna do yarn add
material UI and we're going to also add
material UI I want to double check make
sure what that was but here you icons
okay I think it's always important to
double check when you're adding packages
that you spell everything correctly and
you have the right name it has happened
that people have made packages that had
some malicious code inin in the package
and it was a just a misspelling of a
popular NPM package so be careful with
that
so you eye icons yep everything looks
good let's add it
all right awesome so we have this and we
can do a git status now let's see what's
here and let's just do a commit just to
show we can actually combine the add
step and the commit step if we add this
a flag to a commit and then I'm also
going to combine the commit message step
here so we're adding a.m. so we're going
to get commit a.m. and we're going to
add material UI and we can do a git push
origin git push origin will
automatically push to the master branch
so that's why we didn't have to put a
branch name in case you've seen that
before and you use the branch name we
learned a week or two ago that that's
not necessary
okay awesome so we have this in here now
the next step I think what we should do
is let's add some of those components
that we used on the last project so the
side drawer and the the app bar at the
top we're going to take those and we're
going to add them into our layout
component and of course we're gonna have
to adjust them but we already have the
design for that app bar finished right
we worked on that months ago so we'll
bring up that design which was it's more
than a design we actually built it out
we'll bring that up and then we'll start
to change that app bar to make it look
exactly like we we want it to look okay
so we're gonna grab
[Music]
let's see our layout here here he goes
at bar okay so we got a lot going on
here goodness yeah we have a lot going
on here let's um let's just copy
everything at first and then we can
remove the stuff that we're not going to
use or edit things right so this is get
hopefully going to save us a lot of time
got I've had mixed results with doing
things like this usually it does save
you a lot of time but occasionally you
spend so much time trying to go through
the code and make it work with a new
project that you don't really save that
much time but in this case I think I
think it will be a time saver for us so
we are going to want to leave our Gatsby
link here and react helmet if we
ordinary we may already be using it in
here I think we are let me double check
see what else you have going on here
okay I think we're safe you know what I
don't think we should add this directly
to layouts we should break it down like
we're doing in this other project so if
you it's hard to see here but we have
our layout split up into different
components I think that's going to end
up being better otherwise we're gonna
have one really really large layout
component and it's always better to
split up your components if possible so
let's do that let's create in this case
this is going to be our app bar
components so let's see we'll go ahead
and just create it here and in layouts
so let's make this let's follow our
project structure here do we have okay
this is all just in the layouts folder
so we're just going to make a new file
right here and you can do that right
from your code editor you could open up
you know your file structure and do it
or you could do it from the command line
so I'll try to do it in on the command
line as well and that way if you're not
familiar with it then at least you get
to see how we do that so in this case
I'm going to name it app bar yeah J s
great and I'm gonna copy it in now and
have my calling this up
we're bringing in a par from its hero
you I already and what we want to do is
bring in a par as Mui at bar so let me
explain for a second what I'm doing and
why I'm doing this
so in general it's good practice to name
your component and the file the same
thing right now we're not so our
components name at bar but we're calling
it top bar the reason we did it like
that in our last project was because
material you I already comes with a
component called app bar but we don't
have to call it up bar so we can import
it as something else so we're calling
this material UI app bar so Mui we're
going to prefix it with Mui that way we
can distinguish materialized components
and our custom components if we feel
that we want to name them the same thing
which in this case I do this is an app
bar so I would like to be able to call
it app bar so let's go app bar and if
you're feeling like we kind of just
jumped ahead because we copied all this
code don't worry we're definitely going
to do some components from scratch I'm
not going to be copying and pasting
everything over in this case this will
just help us get a jump start on the the
UI for this project okay and then we
also need to change this name here to
Mui app bar alright now we're going to
save that and we need to make sure of a
few things first I want to look at what
we're bringing in and make sure that we
actually have these things installed
okay this class names did we have to
bring in let me make sure where do we
pull in class names from before
let's see we have several other people
working on this project so I don't
remember we did this so whose if anybody
that was working on this project before
remembers where we pulled class names
please let me know we may not even need
it so I don't want to take the time to
go back through the code right now and
the during the stream that may not be
that exciting so I'll just check it out
later but for now oops we have our app
bar component
and what we'll do with this app bar
component then is we're going to want to
import that into our layout index
component right so we're going to import
app bar from and then we're gonna do I
[Music]
guess
with a dot slash
sound good did I need to dot slash em I
think all right so let's see
let's check out our our index here just
to see how we're kind of piecing these
things together
and we won't need to bring over
everything
but we will definitely need a lot of
these things to handle we're definitely
going to need that searchbar everything
we need to handle search bar okay this
is a little bit more in-depth than I
want to go here in this first opening
stream so I'm gonna switch up and just
work on getting this app bar to the
point where we can have something we can
see that will be it'll be nice we'll
have a sense of accomplishment that we
can see something on the screen alright
so we've imported app bar and now we
just need to use it so let's bring in so
this is the header component and
bringing that in here
all right so this is our current app bar
so if you'll see here right this is the
purple it says Gatsby so you can see
what we're doing here background
Rebecca purple right so we don't need
this anymore and in fact we really don't
need any of this we actually don't need
this header at all so let's just remove
that because instead of header we can
just add app bar all right so that saves
us some space there now when I save this
I don't expect this to work yet because
we're trying to import some stuff that I
don't know that we have so far as maybe
I got my syntax wrong let's double check
I know we did this somewhere else
and see did we do this elsewhere with
our drawer I thought we did
all right let me quickly look up if it
was my syntax implores let's see if
that'll give us what you want
all right this was good oh okay I'm
forgetting my brackets sorry about that
so let's try it again with brackets and
I expect we'll get a different era now a
little bit farther down but we'll take
it one error at a time there we go
cannot be properly appbar of undefined
classes up or okay we don't have these
classes being passed being set up at all
yeah so that was to be expected let's
see if we can pull in some of these
let's see where do we have a year it's
nice oops there are styles
yeah let's pull this whole file in and
we haven't even set up its your UI yet
in our root file totally slipped my mind
so let's do that as well since I already
copied this styles is let's let's make
it a new file and we'll call this style
J us and we'll paste this in save it and
let's let's before we forget anything
else make sure we go in to our index
actually where is
okay this is different
yeah this is definitely different okay
for my people who have used Gatsby
before I'm looking for a route component
where's where's the route component let
me check my timers well
okay okay two minutes and if I can't
find the route component how do we set
up interior UI is it okay it's in public
I mean not the HTML but like normally
you would have an app j/s or something
like that we don't have anything like
that it doesn't look like we have
anything like that right now I mean I I
doubt it's this index but if it was
anything I guess that would be it it's
not this config hmm so is there a Gatsby
way to import material UI then and start
using that yeah here's our Gatsby config
so obviously like that's not what we're
looking for so just to give you an
example what we're looking for either
like art so obviously we have our index
here but I'm thinking more apt is that
we could you can see like everything is
is in here now we did wrap I believe our
layout right in this project we used our
layout index and is that where we added
all our yeah our provider our theme
provider we did in here so I guess we
could do it there
but I guess I'm thinking like what if we
add
on the road what if we decide we want to
use react router can we do that I guess
we don't have to decide on it now but
all right just have to be aware of you
know some of the differences so let's
let's pull this in to our index our
layout index and then let's also
[Music]
and
we're gonna wrap this here
there we go and then we're gonna want
classes first class is
I'm gonna be able I mean we're
definitely enough that this can't say a
stateless functional component so that's
gonna change because we're gonna need
some stuff going on up here
alright so that's going to need a lot of
change so unfortunately we're gonna have
to leave this with an error right now
simply because I don't think we're gonna
have enough time to put in everything we
need to kind of integrate these old
components with what we're doing now
so the the timer is up again let me see
what time it is
okay so we've been streaming for a
little over an hour now I think that's a
good time so I think I'm not gonna do
another Pomodoro session I hate to leave
it off with an error message but I don't
want to do a super long stream today I
have some other projects that I need to
work on and and some of this work is
going to be a little like tedious and
not really that exciting now it's just
going to be comparing files and making
sure that we have you know everything I
need that I'm importing the right stuff
in the component that I've just
transferred and copied so at this point
I'm gonna try to get through all the
questions that are in the live chat if
you have a question go ahead and put it
in there now and if you don't have a
question please stick around and help to
answer the questions I definitely
appreciate having your expertise
okay so I left off right about here okay
aniseh so what are you making is it a
new project yes it is a new project and
so yesterday was the first day I talked
about it so I explained everything
yesterday so if you want to check out
that recording of that stream you'll
have a much more in-depth thing but
basically this is going to be the main
website for the university I work for so
Franciscan edu we're going to completely
redo it it's going to be built with
react we're gonna have content
management system where we're pulling
data from through an API and eventually
we're going to have to set up new
servers new database so a lots going to
go into this but the site itself is
actually somewhat basic there's not
going to need to be any login we just
need we need to display data perhaps
down the road maybe we'll do more but at
least for now to get it launched that's
what we need to do and it needs to be
launched sometime in February or at
least ready for testing maybe around the
beginning of February 2018
okay so Jessie McEntire asks what's the
difference between NPM and yarn that's a
good question so NPM and yarn basically
do the same thing when yarn first came
out the big thing was it was faster and
it also had this yarn lock file okay now
with newer versions of NPM NPM is a lot
faster - and NPM also has their version
of a lock file so anymore
I don't really know that there's that
much of a difference it seems to me like
you can do with yarn the same things but
the commands are slightly shorter to
type in they're more concise but maybe
it's just because I don't know all the
shorthand for NPM commands but at this
point you can use them basically
interchangeably and at least to me I
don't see one or the other as the clear
winner when you're comparing the tooth
okay someone's asking for bank account
hacking tricks we don't do bank account
hacking on on this stream so I'm sorry I
can't help you with that also asked
about Kali Linux as far as I know Kali
Linux is a version of Linux that comes
preloaded with lots of penetration
testing tools I get that's a nice way to
put it so you could use it for good or
for evil I suppose and it looks again
and ray also answered that as well so
thank you for that
oh cool Francis's first to star let's
check out that repo see if I guess I
think we got at least one star right oh
cool eight star is awesome very cool and
I'm going to be filling this repository
with issues and then you can check out
the issues and see if you'd like to
contribute so I need to get a little bit
more done just to set things up before I
can really start putting issues in but
I'd like to start getting them in there
before this week is over so sometime
probably tomorrow
discover Holland says is there a grid
system with material you eye yes there
is a grid system so yes we don't have to
check it out but if you go to if you go
in the material UI documentation for the
for the newest version they have a grid
system actually pretty pretty nice
documentation I think with kind of
interactive examples so yeah they do
have a grid system which is it's very
nice
John Hanson says is there a Gatsby
version specific to material UI at
actually I'm not really sure that's a
good question I didn't check into that
beforehand but might not be a bad thing
to check in to make sure there's no
issues with different versions demon
proxies is he coding a game
unfortunately no that would be pretty
fun but just just a normal website so
not a game right now although I think
it'd be cool if we could do a game on
the live stream maybe one day in
infamouse I guess that's how you say it
says how can you pass the value of the
text input into a function so I'm not
sure if you're talking about
specifically in react or with JavaScript
in general but in react you can I
suppose there's always more than one way
to do it but you know for instance here
we are doing that with R and we find the
component
situation
do we not have a component there we go
so for this we have a let's find our our
textview here we go so we have our text
field here right and then we have our on
change handler so this handle change
right we don't actually have the handle
change here so we have to go up into our
index so we're passing down that
function to this child component but
within here we can see our handle change
maybe I missed it I miss it
let's find it
immature and a close
ladies
where are we bringing this in it
oh there we go maybe we are doing it in
the component it was just underneath so
sorry about that I couldn't find it so
we have handle change and we have this
target so so basically we're passing in
this is an arrow function so if you're
not familiar with that it's it it's
shorthand for a function basically and
it has some different things that happen
with this inside of here
but this is our event our e that's
getting passed in from from whatever
element the change happened and right so
in this case it was the text field so
within that we can go event target and
then name we can get the name of the
input and we can also get the value of
the input and then so this has been
passed into the function then we can do
whatever we want with it and in this
case we're setting the state which this
is called a controlled component
I believe that's what it's called and
that means the state actually that's
really weird so I guess we're not
initializing state with any value first
that's kind of odd anyway we're saving
the value of that component in in the
state and then when the form is actually
submitted then we can get the values
from there so that the probably would
make be easier if this wasn't already a
large build-out component maybe a more
simple example but that's one way and
react at least that you would pass the
value of a text input to a function
it's
okay I'm on says what as asking what is
react helmet for and John Hanson has a
good answers helmet lets you have a way
to set variable head content so if you
know they'll get the top of an HTML
document you have your head so all the
content that would normally go in the
head helmet lets you set with that
content is for each page within react so
it can be really useful you basically
use helmet and let's say your layout
component then you don't have to
manually put it in it it can be a little
bit tricky to do it without something
like helmet so that makes that a whole
lot easier Sebastian says the the
routing is kind of set up like next j/s
yeah I thought the same thing I think
you're exactly right anybody who's used
next before knows it's so far it seems
pretty much the same
it looks like Gatsby has their own link
component just like next does anything
you put in the pages folder becomes a
page so I'm glad that that's familiar so
I won't have to learn a new routing
system bill all says hey Jesse thanks to
the videos do you usually push directly
to master or do you create different
branches when developing I do create
different branches from time to time but
I also do push to master so generally if
the change is going to be somewhat
simple I don't mind pushing the master
now keep in mind too that mostly it's
just me working on the projects mainly
with with some help from you all
sometimes more help some you know so
it's pretty easy to keep the project
kind of under control and I'm
comfortable pushing the master if I had
a much larger team I would be a little
bit more strict about how we you know we
push things and you know having
different feature branches so we're a
little bit loose with
kind of thing right now just because
it's always such a small group working
on it it's okay it works but if I'm
gonna make a more major change like you
know a feature a new feature or a major
design change or something like that
then I usually make a branch for that
and then eventually merge it into master
and then of course all pull requests
obviously are on a separate branch but
I'm welcome to different ideas about how
we can kind of organize the project and
have some rules about you know branches
and things so we're definitely going to
have to make a nice contributing file at
some point
come on says it was fun Thank You Jesse
you're welcome thanks for watching in
assist thank you a lot Jesse your videos
are useful awesome
awesome I'm glad you think that yarn
says so this being a static site with
data pooled from api's will data be
stored or cached and files on the server
you know what I got to look up
specifically what's going on with Gatsby
but I would hope that there's some sort
of caching built in that we can take
advantage of so that a lot of the
frequently accessed pages the the
rendered so we definitely need
server-side rendering I would love it if
the rendered pages would be cast for a
certain amount of time so that that page
can just be served up you know faster
and you know we don't have to make as
many calls you know back to wherever
we're getting our data from so I'm gonna
have to do some more research I knew how
to do that with next j/s and we did that
you know back on project one so I'm
hoping Gatsby can do the same thing it's
not necessarily a deal breaker for me
but it's definitely a feature that I
would like to have
Blake asks how do i deploy a create
react app website yeah Blake there there
are several different ways you can do it
it depends on where you want to host the
website at Amon has a nice link to the
create react app documentation about
deployment yeah I would check that out
Blake so Reid read that section in the
documentation and figure out what where
you want to deploy it to and if it's
confusing here you need some help let me
know
and I can help you out with that but I
think I've deployed two I've deployed
two now or with now I've deployed to get
up pages and then I've also just
deployed to a server to a Linux server
so if you're planning on doing one of
those three things I can definitely help
you out
Osuna says maybe you should add a little
documentation to your source source code
that is a wonderful suggestion I
definitely agree so I am actually I'm
gonna try to do my best to add more
commenting and documentation but that's
also an area where I would definitely
appreciate help if anybody likes that
you know maybe especially if you're not
that confident let's say with your
JavaScript skills if you'd like to get
some pull requests in for your github
profile you know writing a little bit of
documentation or some comments would be
great
you can if you watch the stream or the
videos you'll be able to hear me explain
what the code is doing and then writing
something up like that would be great so
I don't know one should feel obligated
to do anything like that but if that
seems interesting to someone you know
please go for it otherwise I said I'm
gonna do my best to give some good
documentation and comments and
let's see no beer says thanks for the
streaming you're welcome thanks for
watching
okay Philip has some if you remember a
while back Philip asks about sorting
with lodash sort by so he's he's posted
some more in the live chat about that so
like I said I'm not familiar with that
at all but if anybody watching if you
can get to the live chat and check out
the link that he posted in or some of
the stuff I think you know that would be
great I'd love to be able to help out
for someone to be able to help out
Philip I'm really sorry that I don't
know enough about it to be much help to
you John Hanson says react magic state
not initially set for a value and yet it
can still be defined state initially
let's check out that component label
place margin you know what okay this
makes more sense now so normally with
the controlled I may have misspoke
earlier normally with what's a
controlled component which you would use
for normally for form fields the value
is set to equal whatever this state is
if you did that and you hadn't define
anything there would be problems right
but in this case we're not actually
using that state anywhere until it's
already been filled out so it works and
so it it actually works in in this case
I believe correct me if I'm wrong but
with material you I we have this
placeholder and if you were to put a
value here and set it equal to the state
and have it be an empty value or even a
non-empty value you would no longer have
this placeholder visible
the benefit of the placeholder is that
when you click into the input it
automatically removes it I believe that
was the issue that we ran into before so
I think that's why it works in this case
normally though we would want to set or
define what we're going to have in state
beforehand I kind of like defining it
anyway because then it's easy when you
go into the component just to see
immediately what is is going to be in
state right otherwise for this you know
we don't realize until down here that's
we're gonna have some other stuff in
state now also it's it's good to notice
here we're using a target name so we're
actually have a variable name and value
so the key and the value pairs are all
dependent on the name and value of the
input so potentially in this set up we
could add as many inputs as we wanted
and never have to add the input names up
here so there's definitely value in
doing it this way I mean they're pros
and cons to either way if we had a form
that was large and that was likely to
change frequently then doing it this way
is probably the best way to do it anyway
hopefully that made a bit of sense if
you're familiar with react if you're if
you're not familiar with react I hope I
wasn't too confusing with that let's see
okay all right and it looks like below
is gonna try to help Philip so thank you
so much for that that's awesome
so I love it when you help each other
out with with coding issues okay so
we're about an hour and 20 minutes into
the stream now I had a decent-sized
stream we got a lot accomplished and now
we have a github repo up so you all can
see what we've done so far
open issues make suggestions pour
request whatever you want I know we're
early on still so it's not going to be
too easy that you know contribute
there's not a lot of code yet but we'll
get there this projects gonna start
looking pretty good quickly let's see
yep that's it
Oh Diogo says I'm late is this the new
project it is the new project yeah so
I'm a [ __ ] about to end the stream but
you know you can check out the the
recording it should be ready in a few
minutes after I on the stream alright so
I should be back tomorrow around 2:00
p.m. eastern time and I will do another
stream we'll work a little bit more on
on kind of building out our layout
component and thank you so much everyone
for watching for contributing in the
live chat I really appreciate all the
help and I appreciate everyone taking
the time to let me know what they think
about how we should set up this project
I think it's going to be really awesome
I'm really I'm looking forward to
working with you all on this project and
hopefully some of the students here too
that I spoke to some of the students
last night and I hope someone will rinse
[ __ ] well just be a really awesome
you know collaboration to this project
so anyway I'll be back tomorrow until
then have a great day